Having large concentrations of capital coming into an area...
...and bringing best practices is the quickest way to raise more food.
Is it the best way from a long-term sociology standpoint?
I think that's a much more difficult question to answer.
If you look at it today, there are two things I think your audience should understand.
One, 85% of all food calories are consumed in the country where they're grown.
So the food business is a very local business.
Those 15% of calories that trade across boundaries,...
...and where Cargill plays an important role, are critical to certain countries...
...that are not endowed with water resources or land resources.
But the food business at its core is very local.
And so in that context, the way in which land ownership has evolved...
...and will evolve is going to be a big and important question.
At the same time the percent of the world's food that's raised...
...on enormous tracts of land, 'de minimis'.